hey what's up guys my name is Samuel is
I'm a property investor and I wanted to
do a Q&A where people have an
opportunity to ask me questions but I've
picked the questions that are all around
mortgages so I began so many questions
about mortgages so this Q&A Sunday the
theme is going to be mortgages if you
like the idea of doing a themed Q&A
someday then let me know in the comments
below just say themes are good let me
know maybe what you want the next theme
to be if you'd prefer them to be not
themed and just random questions and
just comment below and let me know that
you just want random questions no theme
please comment below theme no theme
comment below a mortgage is a mortgage
is a mortgage all the mortgage means is
it is a loan for you to go and buy a
house that's what a mortgage is so the
different types of mortgages all that
means is if the mortgage is got
different a different purpose so if
you're buying it if you're buying a if
you're buying a property to live in then
it's a residential mortgage if you're
buying a house to rent out it's a buy to
rent out buy to let mortgage but
hopefully that makes it real simple if
it's a HMO property let me say HMO
mortgage because that's the specific
purpose of the loan is to buy a chairman
so don't over complicate it I think it
oh my gosh what's like on a mortgage now
if you're buying a hey chamo property
depending on the type of HMO if it's
just you know you're just renting out 3
or 4 rooms it's a completely normal
house it might be that a lender will
just say it's just a buy to let mortgage
but with consent to rent the rooms out
so buy to let mortgage with consent to
rent the rooms out so it really depends
how the lenders here but my advice is to
just be completely open and honest and
transparent don't try and get a mortgage
on a property and call it something else
don't pretend you're going to live there
if you're not don't pretend it's going
to be a single there if actually you're
trying to rent it out as a serviced
accommodation unis just be honest open
on upfront and if the lenders not happy
with it then find another lender that is
mortgages what are we got so
sm1 says d prefer interest only
mortgages with product fees but lower
rates or without product fees and higher
rates and do you always add the product
fee to the loan amount any help would be
much appreciated thank you for your
question
so I always prefer lower fees I'm very
happy to pay a my fee what this what
this means is a mortgage brokers fee and
mortgage brokers fee is usually in the
hundreds of pounds
unless it's like a large purchase but
you shouldn't pay more than 1% max of
the purchase price for a broker's fee
I'm happy to pay a fee and the reason
I'm happy to pay a fee is because I like
to get the lowest rate the best type of
lender the least hassle and I've found
in my experience that in the long run
you'll save money by using a broker and
your save time so I don't really there's
an old saying that says watch the
pennies and the pounds will look after
themselves I actually disagree with that
statement I think that if you focus too
much on the pennies you lose the pounds
because where your focus goes that will
expand and energy flows so that's the
answer the first half the question the
second part of the question was do I add
the product fee onto the loan amount
which means that the money that I pay
the mortgage broker their fee I actually
add that onto the loan so I don't pay
upfront it just becomes part of the part
of the mortgage yes I always do that if
I can if the mortgage company lets me do
that I'm going to do it why because I
want to pay as little money now and get
as much cash flow as I can
I'm not what trying to be debt-free I'm
trying to be financially free so I
always do that
hold on to the question let's see what
else we've got in regards to mortgages
Harley says what are your thoughts on
over payments on mortgages do you think
that they are beneficial in any way the
answer to that is probably not so I'd
rather over pay a mortgage than be on
reap
and mortgages people that go on
repayment mortgages I think are stupid
because if you go on a repayment
mortgage all that saying is you have no
choice you have to pay back X amount
every month I'd rather be on interest
only and then just overpay if I want
then I'm not a slave I'm not controlled
what I do with my monthly cashflow
however I don't think I would do that
why would you overpay the mortgage
instead I would rather use that money
and instead of over paying the mortgage
I would use it and save it towards the
deposit on another house because I don't
want to be debt free I want to be
financially free I don't want to own
properties outright I want to leverage
my money and the bank's money and have
as a pattern have as many as big of a
portfolio with as much cash flow as I
possibly can so I wouldn't over pay all
the mortgages no Daniel Davis says
interest only is their property drops 30
percent then what okay get this a lot so
what happens if the property drops in
value you know what it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't affect me if
I've got five bought a house for one
hundred and fifty thousand pounds and
I've borrowed a hundred thousand pounds
and one mortgage is 100 grand and I'm
paying four percent interest only so I'm
paying four thousand pounds a year which
is probably going to be about what like
three hundred and sixty pounds a month
but my rent is seven hundred pound a
month and I'm in profit no matter what
happens to the purchase price or the
value of the property so no matter what
happens to that value it doesn't affect
my it doesn't affect my mortgage
payments it doesn't affect my rent so
the value of the property can go up it
could go down but you should never buy a
property with the intention to sell it
unless you're doing a flip but generally
speaking if you buy a property in the
price drops it doesn't matter if the
value drops it doesn't matter ultimately
it's going to go up over time history
repeats itself and that's how we know
that so I'm not worried about the
property dropping in value at all
even if I'm in negative that country
even if my mortgage is 100 grand and the
value of the house is 80 grand and I've
got no equity at all in that property I
don't care
all I care about is that that property
is making me cash flow every single
month that's it so hope that helps so
next we've got Apple car Ahmet
who says hi Samuel what about if my
credit score is low is it still possible
for a buy to let mortgage and the answer
is absolutely yes I'm not a mortgage
advisor so I can't I can't give you
bespoke mortgage advice about knowing
your situation I wouldn't be qualified
to do that anyway but I can let me tell
you this you're the lenders the banks
they don't care that much about you when
it comes to you buying buy-to-let
properties they care more about the
buy-to-let properties because when
you're buying a house to live in
it's your home they care about you
because the home is a liability meaning
it doesn't give you any income it loses
money so when you're buying a home the
bank's want to know can you afford to
live in this home so they'll ask you
questions about how much do you earn
let's see your credit and they'll want
to see it's really good don't want to
see you condone your affordability
checks on you and on the home but when
you're buying a property investment to
rent out they're not that interested in
you or whatever so that's why people
that have got zero income no income
people that have got county court
judgments against their name bad credit
the banks are still lending the money no
let's not just a guaranteed but in many
instances there's still any money why
because they'll say let's have a look at
the house that you want to have money
before the house is good the house is
going to pay the bank
not you does that make sense
so we're buy-to-let it's less important
about you it's more important about
about the house when you bought when
you're borrowing bridging finance
especially they do not care about you
they don't care about your credit I
don't care about your background they
care about the house which is why it's
important to be able to find good houses
the first thing you need to be able to
do as a property investor is finding
good houses you find good houses
there'll be good finance for you believe
me I mean geez
I'll find that's the deal if it's a good
enough house so that's really important
if you've been told no by your bank for
every single question about mortgage
advice I can give you I can give you my
experience but the are usually always
then with go and speak to a good broker
because you always want to have a good
broker if your bank tells you no I've
had situations where 72 year old ladies
are trying to coming up my crash course
and then I try and do deals and their
bank is telling them no way we can't
lend to you and then they write
themselves off that I can't get a
mortgage but then what happens is they
go and speak to a good broker my broker
anyone that does any advanced training
with me will get access to my pal team
and everything everything by the way
you speak to a good broker suddenly
they'll bet they have access to all the
banks and they'll find a broker that
fits you bespoke so hopefully that helps
let's see what else we got on the on the
subject of mortgages maybe one or two
more okay SSH and rub says if you do the
RR strategy I would assume you mean the
RO strategy is by refurb refinance rent
so it's when you add value to a house
and be financed it would you get away
with buying and buying with a buy to let
mortgage and then refinancing once as
banks don't like it
I know bridging loans is the usual way
of doing this okay if you're buying a
house with the whole intention of adding
value to it and then refinancing it when
you first get the house you don't want
to get a normal buy to let mortgage on
the house and the reason is because
normally when you get a buy to let
mortgage there are fees involved but
also you'll have you
like a minimum of maybe two year fixed
and there's no point getting a buy to
let mortgage just to then in a few
months time get another by to that
mortgage because you're just going to
get you just gonna have to pay a lot
more money you're gonna get fines and
all kinds of stuff that penalty fines so
the simplest way to do it is to buy the
property cash add value
- and then refinance and then pull all
your money back out and then with that
cash do it again and do it again and do
it again and keep doing it until you
earn as many houses as you possibly can
before the rules change or whatever now
if you haven't got the cash that's where
you're going to need to get a bridging
finance or use other people's money or
get a joint-venture so yeah don't use a
buy-to-let for that first instance hope
that helps
so guys that's about all we got time for
today on the mortgage Q&A next week
we're going to do another Q&A so if
you've got questions about property
comment them below I'll do my best to
answer as many as I can also don't
forget to let me know do you think we
should do themed or non themed comment
below as well I want to see as many
comments below themed or non themed the
more comments you type below as well it
always helps the YouTube algorithm which
means that we'll get more views which
then incentivize me to make more content
so comment below if you enjoyed the
video please don't forget to smash that
like button and if you're not subscribed
to this channel please subscribe I love
you forever I'll see you next week
thank you
[Music]